iron douze personnalités arrêtées là
points des leaders budget de la défense
à l'assemblée nationale
un effort particulier pour le mari sa
guerre des casinos suite
l'inculpation de jean dominique fratoni
invité du journal d'antenne 2 ce soir
robert fabre premiers résultats de sa
mission sur l'emploi
là messieurs bonsoir ce soir encore à la
une de cette édition
l'iran l'iran qui n'est plus à feu et à
sang mais qui bouillonne encore tout à
l'heure l'armée a encore ouvert le feu
sur des manifestants dans ses rangs six
morts quelques heures auparavant la même
armée avec arrêté douze autres
personnalités parmi lesquelles plusieurs
anciens ministres et même l'ancien chef
de la police politique la savak il n'a
pas bien bonne réputation
par ailleurs une certaine agitation
persiste en province notamment à hama
d'un la 200 km de la capitale de brusque
flambée de violence rapidement réprimées
par l'armée ont troublé encore
aujourd'hui l'ordre qui règne à téhéran
on a relevé simone la rue a peur on
parle de 600 arrestations
tous les journaux ont été saisis par la
censure militaire sauf le quotidien
pro-gouvernemental ouvriers des
imprimeries journalistes ont cessé le
travail pour protester contre la censure
militaire ou de peur d'être arrêtés
la vie normale reprend difficilement
surtout dans les bureaux ou dans les
banques saccagées pendant les aimer
l'art mais pousse les habitants à
retrouver à retourner au travail
mais les grèves prennent encore
l'activité économique du pays
les employés d'accompagner iranair par
exemple continuent leur mouvement
à cause des grèves à la raffinerie de
pétrole d'aba dans l'essence est
rationnée l'armée lance des appels aux
ouvriers et aux techniciens du pétrole
pour qu'ils fassent à nouveau tourner
les rapides et c'est bien là le pari
gouvernement militaire gagner la
confiance de la population pour qu au
moins l'économie du pays puissent
fonctionner normalement
car ce liquide ces précieux pour les
iraniens
elle est aussi pour les occidentaux qui
tire une grande partie leur consommation
d'iran précisément pour la france un peu
moins de 10% notre approvisionnement en
or noir
mais il n'ya pas que le pétrole et les
jeunes français ont aussi noué d'autres
liens avec les iraniens
alors essayons de voir quelles sont les
conséquences des récents troubles sur
les échanges entre les deux pays
l'iran est un marché important pour la
france
un pull magret mise à part c'est notre
premier client au proche orient
c'est à dire parmi les pays à qui nous
achetons notre pétrole et puis la france
est le quatrième investisseur étranger
en iran l'an passé nous avons vendu pour
true plus de 3 milliards de produits
made in france à l'iran dans les travaux
publics les entreprises françaises qui
construisent notamment le métro de
téhéran ont décroché déjà pour plus d'un
milliard de commandes
par ailleurs une trentaine d'entreprises
de bâtiment réalise des logements et des
constructions diverses
de son côté le pétrole et rania
représente environ 10% de nos achats de
pétrole et notre facture pétrolière
iranienne a dépassé 5 milliards de
francs
en 1977 il y à 7500 français qui
travaille en iran à des projets divers
on note une certaine inquiétude dans les
entreprises françaises
même si les grands chantiers comme celui
des centrales nucléaires
réalisez pas la france se poursuivent
actuellement nous concerne la 4s de
ralentir l'activité de notre chantier en
iran la construction de ce projet se
poursuit normalement et titre d'exemple
nous avons plus à l'heure actuelle 450 à
500 ans technicien français présents sur
le chantier puisse un certain nombre de
familles et nous avons maintenu qu'une
personnel sur place et mises à part
quelques perturbations mineures du ou
plus ou moins contents que je demande
certains services iraniens à l'heure
actuelle
normalement à l'étranger toujours
élections aujourd'hui aux états unis les
américains votent pour élire un nouveau
congrès nous n'aurons les résultats
demain matin
disons tout de suite que les démocrates
sont assurés de conserver la majorité
c'est toute la chambre des représentants
qui sera renouvelée de même qu'un tiers
du sénat et je ne compte pas les deux
tiers de postes de gouverneurs et les
milliers d'élus locaux dans notre
dernier journal à 23 heures nous
pourrons écouter la correspondance de
notre envoyé spécial permanent à
washington jacques sig ont pays bas un
scandale le chef du groupe chrétien
démocrate qui fait partie de la
coalition gouvernementale et est accusé
d'avoir été vacciné cesse pendant la
guerre monsieur alan joyce a aussitôt
démissionné il a renoncé à toutes ses
fonctions politiques
enfin des nouvelles du dollar il se
tient toujours bien aux environs de 4
ans 30 mai pour le soutenir davantage
les états unis ont effectué un tirage de
deux milliards de dollars sur le fonds
monétaire international le fmi qui à son
tour a emprunté un milliard de dollars
au japon et à l'allemagne de löw pistes
en france d'abord cette information qui
nous est venue de nice en début de
matinée c'est un rebondissement dans la
guerre des casinos
jean dominique fratoni pdg du casino
rôle l'un des deux grands casinos de la
ville vient d'être inculpé mais laissé
en liberté
le prochain en effet une infraction à la
législation sur les sociétés sur l'omx
30 denis n'est pas n'importe qui son
inculpation après celle d'un avocat
et puis après la disparition de la fille
de l'ancien pdg de l'autre casino niçois
celui du palais de la méditerranée
son inculpation donc met en lumière les
activités d'un personnage assez contesté
alice jean dominique fratoni 54 ans
originaire de corse a commencé il ya 20
ans
monde des jeux avec la direction du
modeste casino de sainte maxime
depuis ces affaires ont beaucoup
prospéré et il contrôle aujourd'hui
quatre casinos l'inculpation qui lui
était signifié aujourd'hui par le juge
dubois this est directement liée à cette
ascension puisqu'elle intervient dans la
sphère du rachat d'un autre casino le
palais de la méditerranée
l'histoire est compliquée mais peut-être
résumer de la façon suivante
madame leroux pdg du palais de la
méditerranée à deux filles qui partage
avec elle un certain nombre d'actions
alors pour obtenir le contrôle de
l'établissement jean dominique fratoni
rachètent des actions à l'une des filles
leroux agnès et en même temps son vote
au conseil d'administration ainsi sans
être directement le patron le directeur
du roule contrôle indirectement ce qui
était un concurrent ce qui était puisque
quelques temps après les nouveaux
responsables jusque le palais a trop de
dette et dépose le bilan
depuis les employés occupent les locaux
pour que l'on rouvre l'entreprise qu'il
juge parfaitement rentable l'inculpation
de monsieur fratoni jugé impensable il
ya un an sur la promenade des anglais
intervient après d'autres inculpations
celle des croupissent indélicats
beaucoup de rumeurs diverses et une
disparition celle d'agnès le roux dont
on est sans nouvelles depuis le 30
novembre 1977
et puis par instant toujours amis c'est
un cri d'alarmé lancé par les cafetiers
limonadiers réunis dans cette vie à
l'occasion du congrès de la fédération
nationale de l'industrie hôtelière
halte au racket voilà plusieurs mois que
le problème couvet de temps à autre un
bar incendié un assassinat parfois même
une tuerie mais de la part des quatre
pieds presque toujours le mutisme
car cette fois ci la profession a décidé
de traiter le problème au grand jour et
le dossier que nous allons ouvrir roux
exalte bien douteux remis à l'industrie
hôtelière représente en france 56 1000
hôtels 220 mille établissements
restaurants brasseries en boîte de nuit
et emploie près de 530 mille personnes
avec 59 mille chambres d'hôtel homologué
la région provence alpes côte d'azur
possède le septième de la capacité
hôtelière française avec un chiffre
d'affaires de 3 milliards de francs
un tel chiffre ne pouvait donc laissé
indifférents les crues en résulta
règlement de comptes en série 24 morts
en deux ans
en jeu le fructueux marché du raquet
devant ce phénomène qui prend des
proportions inquiétantes
les restaurateurs et les hôteliers ont
décidé de réagir et de porter cette
affaire sur la place publique
là si on veut que ça s'arrête il faut
intervenir intervenir tout de suite et
frapper fort
sinon si on ne fait pas ça et bien nous
arrivons à faire en sorte que 80 % de
nos collègues vont se trouver raqueter
de nombreux établissements font l'objet
de sollicitations illicites qui varie de
5000 à 10000 francs par mois
la police est consciente de ce phénomène
mais elle ne peut intervenir sans preuve
d'autant plus que les gérants
d'établissements pour des raisons de
sécurité n'osent pas porter plainte
les truands ont fait du racket
l'essentiel de leurs activités leurs
méthodes conseillé à certains patrons de
boîtes ou restaurants de céder leur
négoce à des prix dérisoires
en cas de refus il tire et sèment la
terreur voit ce qui s'est produit en
changer un gros billets de 500 francs
alors pris en la monnaie
ils prennent des consommations d'eau de
consommation et au moment de payer ils
disent tu t'assois su les mots et je
n'insiste pas sur les mots qui peuvent
venir et apprenait alors naturellement
ils savent qu'on a de l'argent et ils
viennent chez vous
il commence à plus ou moins se battre
entre eux ou à se voir avec des clients
et on intervenait à ce moment là
encore nouvelles de nouveaux problèmes
et puis partent sans payer
il ya bien quelques jours après vous
dise
vous avez envie d'intervenir une bagarre
doit intervenir et ils vous mettent à
l'amande
or voilà comme ça se passe mais si vous
ne payez pas la montre que se passe-t-il
ben ils reviennent où il envoie d'autres
personnes et puis j'essaie de faim ou de
vous frapper ou 10 en intimider et les
clients surtout et faire fuir et
qu'intel de chez vous et à ce moment là
où c'est plus ou moins obligés de vous
payer quoi voilà donc deux affaires jean
françois kahn la guerre des casinos le
racket des hôteliers qui ne sont pas si
dix semaines qu'on peut l'imaginer
apparemment bien sûr
le racket le scandale des jeux où le
trucage des courses ça paraît tout à
fait différent mais en vérité derrière
toutes ces affaires est aussi derrière
le trafic de la drogue est derrière la
prostitution est derrière des règlements
de comptes sanglants
on retrouve toujours un degré ou un
autre
le même jean et je veux parler de ce
dont on peut dire qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui les chefs d'une véritable
mafia française car il y en a une et
vous voyez nous quittons tout à fait là
le terrain du simple fait divers
cela concerne en vérité tous les
français car il s'agit bien au vrai sens
du terme d'un problème de droits de
l'homme car enfin qui sont ils ces gens
qui effectivement apparaissent par leur
richesse par leur puissance par leur
amitié dans tous les milieux comme un
véritable état dans l'état
ces gens qui fréquentent le beau monde
que l'on peut rencontrer dans les grands
restaurants dans les meilleurs hôtels et
qui d'ailleurs fait voter quelquefois
les achète ça leur appartient
ces gens il faut bien le dire que dans
certains films dans une mauvaise
littérature on idéalise un peu qui sont
ils
eh bien ce sont ceux qui empoisonnent
systématiquement la jeunesse française
par la drogue
ce sont ceux qui chosifie la femme par
la prostitution organisée
ce sont ceux qui terrorisent une partie
de la population française par le racket
ce sont ceux qui volent des millions de
petits joueurs par le trucage des
courses
ce sont ceux pour eux tout le retrouve
derrière des grands leaders se sont même
ceux qui tirent les ficelles d'un
certain nombre d'enlèvements en france
et surtout en italie enfin ce sont ceux
qui tuent qui élimine implacablement
tout ce qui les gêne
voilà car d'une certaine manière ils ont
leur propre police leur propre justice
leurs propres joueurs leurs propres
banques leur propre réseau d'import
export et le drame c'est quelquefois on
les connaît et pluton les soupes ça
seulement il se cache qui se dissimule
derrière un paravent d'honorabilité
et il met pas la main à la pâte ils font
travailler leurs sbires et il arrive
effectivement que pour les faire tomber
enfin et bien comme dans le cas de al
capone célèbre il faille c'est un peu
dérisoire mais il faut ce qu'il faut il
fasse quelques fois utilisé larmes du
fisc ah si vraiment c'est une affaire
très bien présente sur laquelle nous
reviendrons dans plusieurs enquêtes dans
les jours à venir les affaires sociales
maintenant d'hambourg ce petit choc
créée par françois ceyrac qui s'est
déclaré partisan de porter à 70 ans au
moins 67 ans l'âge du départ obligatoire
de la retraite
une idée qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
nouvelle aussi nps mais andré bergeron
qui rencontre aujourd'hui françois
ceyrac a manifesté son désaccord et a
estimé par ailleurs que l'on n'échappera
pas à une augmentation des cotisations
de l'assurance chômage
les grèves quelques petits délestages
d'électricité aujourd'hui sur part il
met pas de problème à la sncf par
ailleurs des pompistes mécontents ont
bloqué l'approvisionnement en essence
des grandes surfaces en charente
maritime et dans les deux sèvres
edouard leclerc l'animation des centres
qui porte son nom a réagi en disant que
si les forces de l'ordre intervenaient
pas il le ferait lui-même avec ses
propres moyens consommateurs et
personnel du centre de tri
enfin poursuite de la mauvaise humeur
chez les routiers je ne veux pas parler
dans leur cas de débrayage les routiers
cgt cfdt cette fois se plaignent surtout
de leurs mauvaises conditions de travail
et on entend plusieurs endroits du
territoire ralenti la circulation les
travaux de l'assemblée maintenance
examen du budget de la défense
aujourd'hui budget dont nous avons
commencé à parler hier avec le ministre
yvon bourges et dont nous allons
reparler ce soir avec un reportage de
patrick long reportage que nous avons
axé autour du budget de l'une des trois
armes la marine longtemps en effet se
sentir un petit peu la sentinelle qui
peut mal aimée parce qu'ils de lui
donner de l'argent mais la dotation d'un
sixième sous-marin nucléaire à quelque
peu calmer les appréhensions des marais
cent quarante bâtiments de combat
aujourd'hui peut-être moins de 90 dans
dix ans la marine nationale apparaît à
certains comme la mal aimée du budget de
la défense sur 100 francs déboursés par
chaque français chaque année pour les
armées elles touchent 17 francs c'est
moins qu'en grande bretagne ou aux états
unis mais c'est plus que l'an passé
le grand public est il est vrai peu
informés du rôle de la marine connelly
sous marins
nucléaire on sait qu'ils sont le fer de
lance de la dissuasion mais souvent les
français oublient que les marins n'ont
pas seulement pour but d' attendre caché
au fond de la mer une éventuelle attaque
de notre territoire
je crois qu'à l'heure actuelle des
missions nos marines exerce dans trois
domaines bien précis
tout d'abord le plus important c'est la
mission de dissuasion nucléaire c'est
celle qui prime
tu peux sur toutes les autres missions
vous savez qu'actuellement on s'efforce
d'avoir un ou plusieurs sous marins plus
clair la mer ici pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'une importante flotte de surface pour
les aider lors d'une émission
d'entrevues de sortie la seconde mission
c'est une mission de présence non
seulement prennent nos côtes nous c'est
très loin
j'en prends la présente l'émission de
présence en océan indien puisque la
france c'est essaye d'être la première
marine dans cet océan indien
je prends plein c'est une force
politique très importante enfin nous
avons les missions qu'on pourrait
appeler de service public en temps de
paix qui sont les missions de protection
de nos côtes
les missions de surveillance
je prendrai pour exemple le rail de
ouessant ou encore les missions
d'assistance ou pêche ou d'assistants
des incidences des désistements et les
gens enfin bref des missions de service
public en temps de paix
les missions de plus en plus importantes
dont ge alors même que la marine
nationale est un tournant difficile sur
le plan du matériel pour un bateau neuf
de compte aujourd'hui plus de 15 ans la
proportion est inversée par rapport au
baril
américaines et anglaises un
vieillissement qui est la rançon du
choix fait il ya 15 ans à l'époque c'est
l'option sous marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins qui a été choisie au détriment
de l'option flotte de surface vers les
deux étaient budgétairement a aussi il
est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ces sous-marins
joue effectivement le rôle dissuasif
cinq sont ou vont entrer en service le
sixième l'inflexible sera terminée en
1985 il coûtera plus de 2 milliards de
francs
mais alors même que ces sous-marins
partent régulièrement prendre leur
faction des sentinelles avancer la
flotte de surface elles s'usent
lentement nos escorteur d'escadre
devront progressivement être mis à la
casse pour les remplacer la marine a
passé commande de frégates et le
corvette 13 bâtiments de ce type sont en
fabrication
mais le programme a déjà du retard
deuxième mission de la marine nationale
la présence sur les grands axes et en la
force navale la s'articule autour d'un
grand bâtiment de surface le plus
souvent un porte avions la france en
possède deux ils tiendront jusqu'en 90
leur remplacement de bright
prochainement décide
et puis enfin la marine nationale n'a
pas que les tâches de défense une
présence
elle doit aussi assumer des fonctions de
service public
sur les 11 millions de kilomètres carrés
placés sous sa souveraineté défense
d'une zone économiquement vital mais
protection aussi contre un nouvel amoco
cadiz la marine veille sur les couloirs
de navigation de la manche est là
résonnent les contrevenants les marins
pour cette fonction rêve de posséder en
quantité des avisos ils devront attendre
six sept bâtiments de ce type sont
actuellement en construction un seul
sera mis en chantier l'an prochain un
effort est donc fait dans le budget 79
il permettra seulement de rattraper un
peu du retard acquis depuis 15 ans et
pendant que les députés examinaient le
budget de la défense les employés des
arsenaux manifesté autour du palais bon
j'ajoute que dans le même dossier on
assiste à une petite polémique entre
français et allemands l'armée allemande
viennent de décider d'arrêter
préventivement les wc envol de
l'alphajet c'est un avion franco
allemand ont raisons de sécurité ces
craintes ne sont pas justifiées
simulation dassault le problème de
l'auto défense sera évoquée lors du
conseil me de la semaine prochaine voilà
ce qu'a révélé ce matin sur europe 1 le
garde des sceaux alain peyrefitte alain
peyrefitte qui a par ailleurs évoqué le
cas de youssef kismoune ce jeune
algérien condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle et dont nous vous parlions
hier je suis suffisamment troublés par
cette affaire a dit miser justice pour
avoir mis en marche la procédure qui
peut conduire à une révision du procès
et puis aujourd'hui à lille ouverture
des journées socialiste sur l'europe
journée auquel le ps attache beaucoup
d'importance
onze de ses partenaires étrangers
partage ses travaux parmi les vedettes
vibrante mario soares milhas mercouri
bien entendu françois mitterrand le tout
sous la baguette du metteur en scène de
ces journées jack lang
cette réunion a deux objectifs bien
précis le premier selon le monde pierre
mauroy c'est de donner une âme à
l'europe c'est à dire qu'ici la forme de
la réunion les déclarations solennelles
la tenue de buffet comme ici à la mairie
de lille à ses brillants la présence
d'artistes d'écrivains a finalement
presque autant d'importance que le fond
des discussions le contenu politique de
la réunion sera sans doute assez faible
en juin dernier à bruxelles les
dirigeants socialistes européens
s'étaient déjà rencontrés là il avait
analysé ce qui les rassemblait une même
vision globale de la société et aussi
ceux qui les différenciait une attitude
différente vis-à-vis des partis
communistes et ils ne reviendront pas là
dessus
ici à lille deuxième objectif c'est de
l'envisager l'europe en termes concrets
il ya peu de stratèges politiques ici en
revanche il ya des maires les élus
locaux des responsables venus de 12 pays
différents
tout l'après midi ils ont confronté
leurs expériences dans la grande salle
de l'opéra de lille des idées ont été
lancées comme celle d'une concertation
permanente entre élus socialistes
européens
la soirée sera consacrée à la musique
avec brahms mahler et wagner et demain
l'ouverture solennelle de la campagne
pour les élections européennes
manifestement on a le sentiment que les
socialistes européens ont voulu pendant
ces deux jours montraient prouver
peut-être que du fait de leur nombre et
leur implantation il constitue est
actuellement le premier groupe politique
de la communauté
soixante six représentants sur 198
débuté le socialiste se porte plutôt
bien dans l'europe communautaire mais le
premier groupe parlementaire des neuf
recouvre en fait des socialismes bien
différents par leur sensibilité ou leur
expérience largement minoritaires en
irlande du sud les boues ne rassemble
que 12% des suffrages benelux job des
nuits la hollande n'est plus qu'un ex
premier ministre social démocrate dans
l'opposition depuis un an en dépit de
son poids électoral au luxembourg une
scission a fait apparaître à côté des
socialistes et sociaux démocrates ils
détiennent ensemble plus du tiers des
sièges
et puis la belgique là le psb c'est
assurer une représentation alterne
égales entre flamands et wallons
les socialistes belges participent au
gouvernement au danemark les sociaux
démocrates détiennent le pouvoir
john key organes tels premier ministre
s'appuie sur 37 % des électeurs
et puis il y a les grands de l'europe
l'allemagne est impuissante
social-démocratie plus que centenaire le
parti de brantes et de schmidt
c'est à lui seul plus de 42 % de
l'électorat allemand
déjà 15 députés au parlement européen
la grande bretagne les travaillistes au
pouvoir avec james callaghan le labour
party qui a dix huit représentants à
l'assemblée de strasbourg réuni 48 % des
sièges au parlement anglais l'italie
c'est l'exception moins de 10% des voix
pour le ps si de bettino craxi le
paradoxe veut pourtant qu'un socialiste
occupe depuis pus la présidence de la
république en la personne de sandro
pertini enfin la france où les
socialistes sont les seuls en europe à
faire un choix d'union de la gauche avec
les communistes
voilà pour le socialisme à neuf mais il
faudra aussi compter un jour avec
l'apport méditerranéen le portugal mario
soares et 35% le suffrage socialise
l'espagne felipe gonzalez et 33 %
d'électeurs enfin la grèce qui en compte
plus de 25 %
mais d'ores et déjà on sait que sur les
170 millions d'électeurs européens
un bon tiers vote socialiste ce qui veut
dire entre 130 et 150 députés
socialistes sur les 410 sièges à
pourvoir
donc en l'absence de françois mitterrand
et de pierre mauroy à lille que les
socialistes ont été reçus aujourd'hui à
l'hôtel matignon par le premier ministre
dans le cadre des consultations de
raymond barre sur le cumul des mandats
le financement des partis et le mode de
scrutin l'élection municipale
commentaire de gaston defferre la sortie
nous n'avons pas de propositions à faire
au premier ministre nous l'avons écouté
le parti socialiste ne veut pas être la
route sous couvert de la mer avec nous
maintenant sur ce plateau
robert fabre je ne vais pas vous
demander si vous sentez visé par ces
déclarations parce que nous avons invité
pour que vous nous parliez des premières
conclusions que vous tirez à la suite
des travaux que vous avez engagé
la demande du chef de l'état six
semaines déjà sur les six mois que vous
aidez le frère jacques becker ce que
vous avez eu le temps de trouver les
remèdes miracles pour l'emploi je veux
dire que la traîne en vielle à roue de
secours de personne mais que tout
parlementaire du tome politique a le
devoir de faire des propositions
alors vous en êtes roue de secours alors
ses propositions à 6 ans que je
travaille alors que ces propositions se
sont au bout de trois semaines des
propositions tout à fait partielles et
fractionné et jeudi à dire que le
problème du chômage qui était de plus en
plus angoissant nous allons vers un
million et demi de chômeurs 12% et demie
de plus que l'an dernier
ce problème appelle des solutions aux
gouvernements palais mais aussi
européenne et même mondiale
alors ce que je propose dans un premier
temps correspond avait pas uniquement
aux problèmes d'actualité c'est à dire
pour lesquels des solutions urgentes
sont nécessaires
alors j'aimerais que ces problèmes nous
les abordons un par un devant le
fonctionnement l' agence nationale pour
l'emploi souvent contesté beaucoup sans
plein disent qu'il n'est pas tout à fait
adapté aux missions
oui c'est la gestion du marché de
l'emploi qu'il faut appeler cela car le
chômeurs demandeurs d'emploi qui va à l'
agence d'emploi est accueillie fish est
mis en statistiques
mais il n'a pas la possibilité 40
personnes n'ont pas la possibilité
d'approcher avant des mois
quelqu'un qui puisse l'orienter le
diriger véritablement vers sa
qualification alors là il ya un problème
il faut donc ce rapport donné à la chose
non pas des moyens supplémentaires faut
créer des unités dans le pays
il faut régionaliser et il faut
humaniser il faut qu' il ya beaucoup à
faire rire domaine alors maintenant
l'indemnisation du chômage est elle
suffisante
la nomination du chômage les contester
est contestée parce que c'est très
inégalitaire certains touchent l'aide de
minimal la clinique c'est-à-dire 16
francs cinquante par jour et est même
parfois moins au fil des années mais
entraînaient un bon sommer un ligne rob
il s'en tirait bien oui parce que cela
touche 90% d'un plafond qui certainement
devrait être révisée vers la thèse du
trampoline jarry faudrait de faire deux
choses augmenter l'aide publique
pas possible de vivre avec 12 francs par
jour et puis il faudrait et que dans un
esprit de solidarité
il y est abaissement du plafond à 1000
francs par exemple par mois de manière à
ce que chacun puisse avoir une part de
la répartition de cette indemnisation
3,8 troisième d'aussi concret les
charges sociales les entreprises se
plaignent qu'elles sont souvent trop
lourde
oui c'est un énorme problème non parce
que c'est très coûteux les sciences
sociales un point de charge sociale
parce qu'on a assez miliani donc
lorsqu'il faut aller vers l'allègement
ne se charge sociale il faut mettre en
face le coût de l'opération
mais je crois qu'on peut commencer par
un certain nombre d'expériences certains
domaines
l'industrie de main d'oeuvre dont est
allégée car l'erreur est de faire porter
la charge sociale uniquement sur le
salaire alors ma première proposition il
y en aura d'autres sera d'accroître le
seuil haut niveau de l'artisanat du
nombre de ceux qui ont des avantages
sociaux et fiscaux est du nombre de vis
actuellement au nombre de 15 10 ans
privées et cela permettra gindrat nombre
de créations d'emplois très important
dernier problème et on verra celui des
retraité edmond j mule c'est pas le
moine mais beaucoup sert également de
d'exemple si choquant oui je suis aussi
qu' il y a le problème de ce qui
libérerait à à 35 ans par exemple ou de
l'armée doivent avoir une autre activité
cela il faut le mettre à part ce
problème là je n'aurai parler que de
ceux qui arrivent à l'âge de la retraite
j'entends tout à l'heure mais ce sera
bien il faut reculer encore l'âge de
retraite
moi je dis qu'il y a le droit à
l'activité sans limite d'âge
et puis il ya le droit au repos alors
pour ceux qui voudraient choisir la
solution du repos il y faut abaisser à
la carte
l'âge de la retraite à 60 ans mais alors
son mandat actuel avec les attendait
d'avoir les avantages donnés à 65 ans
c'est à dire avec une retraite pleine
permettant de vivre et à ce moment là en
corrélation supprimer les cumuls car il
ya dans ce domaine vous l'avez dit un
certain mal à vue qu'il faut réveiller
merci robert table d'avoir regardé pour
en perdre et donc les premières
conclusions
de votre mission sport maintenant voile
avec la route du rhum est d'abord la
confirmation de l'abandon de jean pierre
milet son trimaran a éperonné hier une
épave au large de portsall et oui non
loin de la carcasse de l'amoco cadiz les
ennuis aussi pour yvon fauconnier qui a
connu des avaries de pilote automatique
mais qui lui pourra repartir de brest
football avec la composition qui
s'inscrit sur votre écran de l'équipe de
france qui demain disputera son dernier
match de l'année au parc des princes
contre l'espagne match qui sera je vous
le rappelle retransmise en direct sur un
thème de denain donc à 20h30 la page dit
air-air avec tout d'abord la première
récompense de la saison le prix
aujourd'hui pour hélène carrère
d'encausse ce prix réservé à une oeuvre
historique ou politique est décerné par
un jury de journalistes
il récompense cette année donc l' empire
éclaté sanou rage sur l'union soviétique
paru chez flammarion
et puis salon la naissance d'un nouveau
confrère la revue française de
communication chacun des articles
publiés par cette parution trimestrielle
le présente la particularité d'être
suivie d'un résumé en anglais la page
variété maintenant pour conclure ce
journal avec henri tachan à l'olympia
c'est la première fois que cet auteur
compositeur interprète affronter tout
seul hier soir le public de cette salle
henri tachan un chanteur de grand talent
qui fait souvent penser à brel mais
beaucoup trop méconnu derrière lui le
seul accompagnement d'un piano et avec
lui le public qui a retrouvé ses fureurs
et ses révoltes
ces révoltes d'écorcher solitaire quel
goût ça un lendemain de créances très
bon ou très bon goût parce que la veille
c'était plutôt difficile bref on entre
en scène bien combien d'années que vous
attendiez cette soirée ça fait 12 ans
que je chante
j'ai bien aimé cette soirée mais c'est
pas fini je veux dire ça commence
jusqu'à présent il y avait eu beaucoup
de difficultés à imposer henri tachan
parce que avec les mauvais caractère une
attitude écorchée vive il est vrai ouais
c'est vrai j'ai mauvais caractère je
suis encore chérif jeu c'est
insupportable je suis casse-pieds le
surhomme herder bon c'est tout ça c'est
les qualités de tout ça c'est les
défauts et mes qualités
j'avais vraiment changé ils sont comme
tous les gens changent c'est vrai cette
phrase glisse il ya quelqu'un qui change
pas mais c'est vrai c'est bien de
changer parce que chaque jeudi à changé
en avoir un petit peu vers les autres et
ça fait comme un peu rire fin sourire
parce que il ya quelqu'un qui serait il
ya deux ans j'ai chanté une chanson sur
scène forme il dans le tour de chant il
ya un type venu me voir après qu il m'a
dit ah quelle tendresse
qu'est ce que tu as changé qu'elle
regarde les chansons qu'il ya des crises
j'ai remercié avant j'aurais dit connard
je l'écrivais il ya 15 ans mais et
souris je suis passé outre ceux sur le
cul des dogues et bigot tiges en regard
de tons doux
ce
le par ce courtier dit que d'espoirs
matin
c'est bien moi ou cote a gagné 7 août au
fond du vent enfouis attend de son
sa simple et bruce cauvin
après quatre ans plus tard
c'est ce qu'on avait en essence lorsque
l'on est innocent la tondeuse
ce tout ce qui nous reste encore pour
faire un pied de nez à la bonne du tout
doux
le
mais nous reprendrons mans vers la météo
aujourd'hui un temps frais mais
ensoleillé sur la majeure partie du pays
pour demain et trois zones pluvieuses du
bassin aquitain à la manche suivie
l'après-midi des éclaircies sur le reste
du pays
après une matinée fraîche le temps sera
souvent en sol et voilà dernier
rendez-vous avec l'actualité ce soir le
journal de gérard holtz vers 23h30 point
final de la présente édition
je vous remercie de votre attention et
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
demain